it was either you or grandma and grandpa
and he looks right at me and he goes
well they do like each other a lot
i didn't the answer is jacob did it and
didn't jacob did it did jake's guilty my
wife and i we went to hawaii for
vacation my parents came to stay with
them we got a direct tv bill a month
later and there's 200
worth of porn charges
you know it's such an old person thing
to order porn off a tv right probably
not a lot of point on the tv when you
were growing up there was not a lot of
tv
on the tv
bad i'm mad mad right the dude needs to
be taught a lesson because porn is free
like how dumb do you have to be
not only is porn free but all folks
even though they might like to watch it
they probably don't know how to get it
i got pouring in my pocket 24 hours a
day
i'm worried about him as a human being
if he's still paying for porn that is
the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever
heard of
i'm worried about him walking around in
this world if he's still paying for porn
i tell my wife i'm like i gotta go down
and talk to him this is so dumb i'm
playing the innocence until you prove
that i'm guilty i'm like all right but i
can't argue that anymore there should be
a
tape for white collar criminals
run by their lawyers
do what this kid did
so i have the facts in my hand i have
the bill in my hand so i figure it's
gonna be quick conversation so i go down
into his room and i'm like hey man you
know anything about this and here's how
i could tell he was gonna lie to me
because as soon as i held up the bill
he bent over and he squinted like he
couldn't read all of a sudden he was
like even when there was nothing to read
if you were caught in a lie you were
i'm not sure what that list of stuff is
i'm like it's porn he goes oh
i know you don't know anything about
that porn you just know i know because
i'm looking at the dates it's when your
mom and i were out of town
and the only people at the house were
you and
grandma and grandpa
i really feel sorry for josh because he
doesn't know who he can trust and i
would assume that you are watching porn
before my mom she might be fascinated
with technology nowadays she didn't have
it when she was my age the whole notion
of my parents
having sex
is unsettling that's a good word for it
why is he so confident i have the bill i
have it right here i'm gonna make him so
uncomfortable that he'll admit it so i
guess i'll just start reading off the
titles of the movies
are you telling me
that grandma and grandpa
were in my room
watching
anal party 3.
and this is the quote out of his mouth
well the door was shut all weekend
you would think you would at least throw
me a bone and be like yeah it was me
because then i wouldn't have to think
that my mom was watching anal party
three we were innocent thank you for
saying that i've been plotting i can't
wait for him to have a kid i know we're
coming over i'm doing something and i'm
blaming it on your kid the reason he was
so confident was the only way i can
truly prove that it was him
is if i call my parents
and i say
did you watch anal party 3
in my room
and on the off chance they say yes i got
to burn the [ __ ] house down like i
can't live there as an adult male 1
here's the one thing that i hang my hat
on
is when i ask i go why don't me you and
grandpa just do a video together he's
like nah he goes i want to do that to
grandpa
and i said what do you mean he was like
well i don't want to have to put him in
a position to lie i was like i don't
think that's the position just peace of
mind i can't think about that i slept on
a bed that my mom and dad were watching
anal party three on you say are you
doing it for peace of mind but based on
this you don't have any pieces i have
zero pieces yeah that's the best part
yeah i decided that he's gone all in he
knows i don't want to call my parents
the only way i can bust him is if i go
all in too and i say to him i go you
didn't order porn and then he did say
what every teenager says at least once i
wish you'd just believe me god spoken
like a true
winner yeah
what would you like me to do for you
today
admit it
how you gonna know man
i believe you and he goes whoa
because i figured i'm pushing all my
chips in too the only way to get him is
to admit it is to get him into a
situation that he doesn't want to be in
so i said yeah man
i believe you and i think it's terrible
that grandma and grandpa are making you
pay for their porn he was like yeah i
think that's terrible too because you
were so adamant about me ordering the
porn and that your mom didn't i'm not
going to say your parents anymore i'm
just going to say your mom that's going
to bother me
we got to call him out he was like i
agree with you let's just get him on the
phone
and he looks me dead in the eye and he
goes
call him
when you said call him what was the
thought process no matter what hillary
went down whether grandpa decided to
blame me or they came out and said the
truth
i was ready for the ride and at this
particular point
i think we can take the fork out of you
yeah
you are done
i was ready for the roller coaster
because i just wanted to hear you ask
say you're telling the truth which
you're not
which
which
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
were you expecting them to admit it
no only the two of you know so it's
funny because grandpa and i have never
talked about this right i did ask my dad
i go hey did you order the porn and he
goes jacob hasn't said anything and i
was like no and he's like oh well then
i'm not gonna mommy he knows the answer
you both know the answer and he's
running it with me now wait
jacob
you lost me there yeah
so
confident i am not participating in your
charade let's just get him on the phone
and he looks me dead in the eye and he
goes
call him
so i start to dial one number
dial another number and he goes
you don't have your parents on speed
dial when you said that i was like
it was so cocky i liked it so much you
were ready you're like let's get this
phone call happening yeah man because i
think you knew i was never going to call
i knew you were bluffing yeah there was
no way of what if my mom answered
exactly you
were waiting for him to walk into the
bear trap
and he had had enough practice he walked
around it
no he just moved it over to your leg
and you walked into it i'm going slow
i'm giving you a chance to come clean he
goes i wouldn't say come clean when you
talk to them and i was like
listen guys if this is a fight he's
landed every [ __ ] punch so far i'm
pressing another button
press another button guys i'm at like
the eighth button i'm like i'm about to
ask my parents if they watched anal
party three i was so nervous i think i
saw you sweating you don't give up on
bits you go all in nobody else is
hanging out of the bow you're still in
the titanic like we still got a chance
yeah yeah
everybody's already given up and on a
lifeboat and i'm sitting there at the
camera as well i'm like we got that
about to press that ninth button and he
goes whoa
i'll pay for it
that's perfect i'll pay for it i'm not
admitting that's any guilt and i said
you ordered the porn he goes no that was
grandma and grandpa i just don't want
you to embarrass them i think it's nice
how much they like each other hey jake i
don't like
what you just did for us yeah me neither
what you did is you made sure that i
never knew the answer you never got a
definitive yes or no
and you also knew that i was going to
end up paying for the bill and probably
never ask you for the money even at that
age you knew you were like wait wait
wait wait
not knowing is going to be way worse
than knowing right 100 it's a great joke
because it's never ending isn't as long
as you and grandpa
never say anything and neither one of
you says yeah
it hangs over my head like a
[ __ ] anvil look at that ah smirk
smirk
he looks me dead in the eye and he goes
we done here and i was like
yeah i guess so uh
but that wasn't satisfactory to me guys
i needed to hear him say he ordered the
porn right so we get to the outside of
his door and i'm on the outside of it
and i go hey man before before before i
leave i'm going to give you one last
offer i
will pay the bill and give you 200
all you got to do is say you ordered the
point
and he looks right at me and he goes
nope
grandma grandpa
and now every time he walks by my room
and the door is open he looks in and he
goes i wouldn't sleep on that bed best
line ever offering a 16 year old would
be 400 bucks but to me it's just 200
that's when it clicked in my head that's
when i was playing the game at that
point you were like i don't even care if
you did it or didn't i just need to hear
the words yes i ordered the porn come
out of my mouth so that you could take
the thought of your parents or your
mother out of your head you
giving me the peace of mind that i
wanted wasn't worth only two hundred
dollars oh [ __ ] the joke is too good i
think i'm telling the truth you don't
think you're telling the truth that's
right you're telling the truth well no
but if worse gets the worse remember
that we're in our 80s and we don't by
the way of course just yet
for more sitting worse has already come
to worse right yeah yeah yeah you're
done yeah yeah yeah you were toast
24 day i'm living liquor just to make it
through another 24.
we'll have a shot that got me constantly
smoking i'm getting high just to balance
out the lows and they always tell me
that i should
[Music]
another day another dollar howler 7 pm
what's it gonna break another bug